we've made enormous progress in my  lifetime  on race in this country a lot of people  aren't willing to admit that  but when i was a kid and a black person  came on television  and  they were in a non-servile role this was  a big deal you called everybody in come  and see this  now you have black admirals and generals  and ceos of fortune 500 companies and  heads of foundations  uh university presidents including ivy  league we've elected a black president  twice black vice president  you know to say that we have made  progress is absolutely ridiculous  doesn't mean we reach nirvana  and we still need to continue to make  progress but we've made a lot of  progress and we should we should  decide that we're going to build our  future  on the progress  and not  on the things that were embarrassing  about our country